[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's brandon staley the chargers head
coach he was with the rams he's been in
a variety of places he's been at
tennessee he's been at hutchinson
community college
john carroll university st thomas in
minnesota
and yes you would have thought he would
end it up with the chargers as the new
head coach he's
brandon staley did i miss anything on
the resume there brandon of
all your stops here yeah northern
illinois
james madison and then you know chicago
denver
the list is long and distinguished if i
would have told you when you were john
carroll
six years ago hey you're gonna be an nfl
head coach you would have said what
i would have said that you know i
believe that i could do it i think
you know that's the belief i had in
myself and i think the people that were
with me
at carol would verify that but i think
they would probably be the only people
that would verify it uh in the world um
and i understand that
you know a lot of people you know uh you
know needed google to figure out you
know just exactly who i was but um
you know i think you know what i've
tried to do is you know every
opportunity that i've received is just
try to
you know prove myself and and hopefully
with this
opportunity i'll be able to do the same
thing and i don't know
it was probably 20 years ago i'm at the
university of dayton i see this
18 year old freshman and i'm in the
communications building and uh
and i saw brandon steve i've never told
this story
and he said he wanted to be in the media
and i said
son you look like a football coach and
uh and that was it that was all i said
to him and
i can now tell that story publicly we
did it brandon
we did we did it yeah i'm one of the few
people that know you know your full name
i'm aware of like where it all began and
uh
so you know i like i said flyer pride
we are ud and uh he was also the
starting quarterback
who plays in the nfl the way you played
at dayton
oh man um that's a good question dan
uh i would say maybe a little baker
mayfield
you know maybe a little baker because i
wasn't you know wasn't the you know the
tallest guy six-footer mobility but not
like
an elite athlete but good enough and you
know
competitor um i think baker certainly
throws it better than i did but
that could be a decent comp a better
college quarterback you were sean
mcveigh
brandon staley sean mcveigh played a
receiver oh i thought he was a uh
a quarterback yeah high school high
school option quarterback okay
i moved a receiver oh okay so then you
were a better college quarterback than
he was
[Laughter]
how do you sell yourself in an interview
to be the head coach because you do have
to sell yourself
i'm guessing well i think dan you got to
be yourself
number one and i think that you know so
much about a head coaching interview
it's just expression you're
expressing your vision um for how you're
gonna lead a team
uh and i think that you know it's you
know it's a difficult job because it
requires a lot of different skill sets
to be good at it and i think what you
got to try and do
is is share your vision for all the
parts of the job not just
you know defense or offense or the
kicking game but you know
how you're going to lead everybody in
the building you know how are you going
to connect
you know to your players how you're
going to connect to fans um
you know how are you going to organize
schedules and um how are you going to
lead a team you know 365 days out of the
year and so
um you know that's why i've been working
so hard throughout my whole life because
this is
this has been my dream and i've been
working towards it and i think in that
interview
i was able to express all the things
that i've been working so hard for and
you know i was fortunate that's what the
spanos family tom telesco
ed mcguire that's that's what they were
looking for and um it really really fit
well
um in the interview process but also
being an offensive minded guy
as a college quarterback at what point
do you make the shift to being a
defensive
minded coach yeah i think that my
background dan
you know as a quarterback has really you
know i think sort of
shaped the trajectory of my career as a
defensive coach because i think when you
see the
the game through the lens of the
quarterback it's just going to change
you knowing
that you're responsible for all 22 every
single play knowing
you know the responsibility that
quarterback has within the team
the locker room you know outside i think
you know my defensive philosophy
has certainly been driven by my
experiences as a quarterback
and you know trying to make it tough on
that position because the reality is
this is a quarterback league and and you
look no further than the four teams that
are playing right now
um you have to be able to you know
compete with these guys ultimately to be
successful and then
when you're the head coach of a team you
know you need to be able to help
your quarterback you know become as good
as he can be
you interviewed for other jobs right
eagles texans were you offered those
jobs
i was not no i this is uh this is the
first opportunity that was offered to me
and
uh this is the one we were shooting for
and it was such a great experience to go
through that process
and i think it became clear to to me and
my family
uh that that this was the place that we
were hoping uh would choose us
and you don't have to move do you just
right down the
right down the road i know my wife that
that's early christmas present i i won
husband of the year
um you know and didn't even really you
know
need to get to christmas to do it so um
you know we're off to a good start in
this new year and uh you know
my family and i have really fallen in
love with california and and i you know
in a short time and during a pandemic so
i can only imagine what this place is
like when
um you know it'll be up and running so
we're so excited to be a part of the
southern california community
we're talking to the new chargers head
coach the pride of perry ohio is brandon
staley who do people
say that you look like you get mistaken
for anybody
um you know there have been some like
matt liner
johnny knoxville you know there have
been some people that have kind of gone
like that direction
um you know i can see the knoxville i
can see and i also thought of peter
brady from the brady bunch
not as familiar with peter but um you
know
you know i'll have to look him up yeah
but yeah yeah i think that those are
some a few that have been thrown at me
uh whether or not they're accurate i
don't know
johnny knoxville i i could see that you
have you i'm sure you have a personality
that is
nothing like johnny knoxville well i you
know i love to meet the guy i know he's
good at what he does
so i know i've watched a lot of his
movies so maybe uh we can connect at
some point
what was that first meeting with justin
herbert like
uh special you know on the way home
after i called my family you know i
really
you know something that's important to
me dan is just reaching out to the guys
and
just being able to connect with him
right away and then yesterday on our way
to the press conference you know we kind
of facetimed him
my wife and i because you know i wanted
him to share in this special day because
you know he's at the front of everything
that we're doing and
you know we got to really pour into him
because um he has so many special
qualities that we're excited to get
working with and
um you know certainly one of the
highlights of of this opportunity and
uh and with that comes great
responsibility so um
looking forward to getting started with
justin for sure before i leave you or
let you go you got other
important things to do but i i know
cancer has played a role in your life
and uh if you could maybe uh deliver a
message to this audience of
what you've gone through your parents
have gone through
and uh sort of the importance of that
and even you singled out shelley smith
one of my uh
good friends at the press conference who
uh went through cancer and uh
a wonderful reporter and i don't know it
touched me that
that that you singled out shelly smith
with everything she's gone through but
you've certainly gone through some
things yourself
yeah i think it was just one of those
moments it was almost like my mother was
you know kind of watching down on us you
know uh
but both my parents had cancer my dad
just went through prostate cancer
treatment
in the fall you know thumbs up you know
got a really good report but my mom
passed away when i was in college she
had
breast cancer that turned into a lot of
things for for nine years and i just i
saw a lot as a young guy
growing up and her strength her grace
her resilience and
um and then when you go through it
yourself when you were actually feeling
it you know i went through hodgkin's
lymphoma
when i was 24 and you do six months of
chemotherapy six
weeks of radiation when you come on the
other side of it there's just a strength
there's a
there's a confidence there's a feeling
that you can't really explain and
when i saw shelly smith you know when
she was going through her treatment you
know
i mean i grew up watching espn i grew up
watching you and stuart and
and all those people there that made
that so special i was one of those gym
rats you know
uh studying all that i could and and
watching shelly go through what she went
through i just saw a lot of the grace
and and that my mother had and um you
know it was a really cool moment
and uh you know i think that if you see
me here today hopefully for any
boy or girl growing up going through
something difficult maybe it's not that
but something
you know really challenging um if you
come on the other side of it if you
believe in yourself
that your dreams can come true wait if i
would have said to you
five years ago do you want to be a
sports center anchor or do you want to
be a head coach
about 20 years ago if i said you want to
be a sports center anchor
or a head coach what would you say i'd
say that i'd have a good chance at both
um i'd say that whatever i put my mind
easy easy here with he had a good chance
at both
i mean it's hard there's a lot of guys
who coach the chargers there's very few
people who can really
do sports center here brandon well well
i grew up i grew up you know getting you
know coffee early and reading a sports
page and then watching
all of the sports center reruns that's
when sportscenter had the you know
you know like that's what my brothers
and i were doing so um
you and stuart and everybody i mean we
were you know we were those young kids
that were reciting lines like you know
that we knew something so
um you know just i think we just grew up
around the game sports
just in general and so uh i think all of
it kind of led to this and
you know uh it's good glad glad i took
this path because i wouldn't be nearly
as
uh you know believable or watchable as
you are
oh well i understand that but uh
good luck with this it's a great moment
for you and uh certainly a proud moment
for uh all involved including your
family
um and uh we are ud so uh
take that same fighting spirit there
that uh you would have had it dayton
and uh bring it to the chargers thank
you dan
new head coach the chargers brandon
staley